do you swear that the testimony you are
about to give shall be the truth
this set of pardons includes more
figures swept up in the investigation
into russian meddling in the 2016
election
robert mueller in his own words quote
did not find that the trump campaign or
anyone associated with it
conspired or coordinated with the
russian government end quote
but several in the trump campaign's
orbit were convicted
as a result of their conduct during the
investigation or for unrelated crimes
that were dug up as part of the
increased scrutiny
both are true for former trump campaign
chairman paul manafort
he was convicted of obstructing the
russia investigation
but also several counts of bank and tax
fraud related to his political
consulting work for the ukrainian
government
before he joined the trump campaign for
sam manafort's pardon
confirms the suspicion they had during
the russian meddling investigation
democratic congressman adam schiff
tweeting during the mueller
investigation
trump's lawyer floated a pardon to
manafort manafort withdrew
his cooperation with prosecutors lied
was convicted
and then trump praised him for not
ratting trump's pardon now completes the
corrupt scheme
lawless until the bitter end it was a
witch hunt
there's no question about that longtime
political operative and friend of donald
trump roger stone was also convicted of
lying to congress
and to mueller during the russia
investigation his 14-month sentence had
already been commuted by donald trump in
july
the father of donald trump's son-in-law
jared is also on the list
charles kushner was given a two-year
sentence for tax evasion
witness tampering and illegal campaign
contributions
he notoriously filmed his brother-in-law
with a prostitute
and then sent the tape to his sister in
an attempt to prevent her
from cooperating with prosecutors there
had long been an
expectation that in the last days of his
presidency donald trump would pardon
those he felt had shown him loyalty
during the russia investigation it has
nothing to do with the merits of the
individuals who are being pardoned and
everything to do with
whether or not donald trump wants to
show them special favor
uh based on whether or not they have
been loyal to him or whether or not they
have a special connection to him
as in the case of jared kushner's
father it is being used as a political
tool in this case which was precisely
what it was
never meant to be also as expected trump
vetoed the national defense
authorization act the 740 billion
legislation passed by congress that
funds defense spending
president trump had objected to
provisions designed to slow down the
withdrawal of u.s
troops from afghanistan and the renaming
of u.s military bases
currently named after confederate
generals the president had also called
for the insertion of a provision
removing legal protections for internet
companies into the ndaa
however both the house and senate are
expected to meet next week to override
the presidential veto
shia britancy al jazeera washington